whenever you have any relationship issue
whether it's your you don't know what to
do on your date you don't know what text
your date you don't know how to
interpret a text you're struggling in
your relationship you you don't know if
you want to get married
you don't know if you want to break up
you have broken up but you want to get
back together so any kind of
relationship issue that you have
we're basically your hotline 24/7 where
you can connect to a qualified certified
relationship coach who actually knows
what they're talking about who's talked
to thousands of people just like you who
has a playbook for your exact situation
and you can get you know very
personalized contextual help know
someone's opinion may contradict yours
where's my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we if what is
the nature of this reality what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sake on we are now gonna be
talking about relationship hero
we have Leon Shapiro joining us on the
show hi Alan thanks so much for coming
on yeah great to be here I'm super
excited for this episode for those who
don't know Leon's background he's
co-founder and CEO of relationship hero
which is the number one relationship
coaching service in the world they have
over 100 full-time relationship coaches
available 24/7 via phone or online chat
and you can find the links in the by
below relationship hero comm also Leon's
LinkedIn and Twitter profile also of
course as we have Oreos or co-producer
you are his brother with the same last
name yes and it's so fun having you here
and hanging out together let's jump in
with one of our favorite questions
without asking our guests what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world
all right well in my own opinion I think
the direction of the world is good you
know it's if you read Steven Pinker's
enlightenment now he really details all
these things that are really going the
right way
and there's you know there's a really
good TED talk by hands Rosling that I
recommend checking out about you know
how all these countries are getting
lifted out of poverty everybody's
getting food to eat he makes a big
distinction between making like one
dollar a day and four dollars a day and
after that making like a hundred dollars
a day so you're really seeing a lot of
movement toward people just like having
less horrible [ __ ] in their lives and
just like more of having like a decent
life that's like a major trend we're
seeing and I think it gets lost in
people who are like complaining or
bitching about like little things like
oh you know we're having privacy issues
online like yeah there's all these
little problems but you have to keep it
in a sense of perspective of like hey do
you not have diarrhea every single day
and that's like a big improvement so I
don't think I'm saying anything new here
but I just try to keep things in
perspective that I do think we're
overall on the right track yes yes okay
so basic needs being met for people
around the world enabling them to have
clean water a meals to eat every day
less disease better health that our
education
these are critical absolutely critical
and flourishing is increasing in all
those respects around the world
simultaneously a lot of the major
technology challenges that we face now
are of unprecedented scales and just
have not been dealt with of an in any
sort of capacities in the past at the
same levels as what we're experiencing
now so maybe what would be some of your
key like points or maybe like an
essential skill or advice that you would
recommend young people and adults to
embody as we go into the exponential
technology age hmm yeah what's girl
should you and body I think there's
thinking tools that are helpful so you
know just understand how to analyze
things with a sense of perspective so
like you know what I was saying about
the world is like you know can you zoom
out from the random discussion you're
having on Twitter and and
you know an actual statistical trend
that's a global scale keep that in mind
and then in terms of technology like
yeah I do think that just getting
educated in technology is like a
powerful tool and it's getting harder
and harder to insist on doing things the
old way right so you have to be beca
adaptive to change yeah that's the good
general approach yes yes I liked that a
lot
the likely one of the most critical
aspects of worldview development is to
be able to both zoom out into this macro
perspective on viewing the entire planet
and eight billion nodes moving around
and seeing how they're engaging with
each other like we were talking about
people getting uplifted with their basic
needs and simultaneously going into the
micro and identifying the in a
scientific way identifying what's
happening at the atomic level the
cellular level but also seeing what's
happening at the human level in a
one-on-one eye to eye knowing how to
practice emotional intelligence motion
regulation growth mindset
perspective-taking there's so many of
the different complex nuances
interpersonally to to develop so these
phenomenon of scales and really being
able to kind of go between them is such
an important skill yep later on how did
you first get interested in computer
science from your grown up well I had a
computer in my room it was like an old
Apple SC desktop computer and I was just
clicking around on it I just loved it
you know I loved all the logic of it and
you know stuff would happen when you
click and it all had like its own logic
and it was you know really had all these
details it was just like this very fun
game right and I even remember before
that as like a 5 or 6 year old just
having all these toys and the toys would
all be like kind of boring right like
there wasn't too much you can do with
them and like but some of the toys that
I've liked speakers and some of the toys
would have like maybe a couple lights on
them but then the computer was great it
was like so much richer in terms of you
know stuff it could do so that was like
my first computer memory and then when I
was around
nine then I started learning you know I
started seeing places where you could
type some code and I checked out like a
math book from the library and it told
me about writing some code so I got my
hands on a basic editor you know the
programming language basic so I've just
started tooling around writing my own
code and it was just amazingly fun right
it really like clicked with you know
it's kind of like I was born to have
some sort of hobby like that right and
so if I wasn't around and like the 90s
if I was around like a thousand years
ago I probably would have been like
making stuff out of wood right and that
would have been a lot less fun than
computers all right so what was it about
did you do you feel when you were
younger also the the sheer amount of
power that you had being able to work
with computer logic and just what you
could tweak and how you could manipulate
binary code to output whatever you
wanted and just did you feel the power
of that at a young age I definitely felt
a lot of the power yeah it definitely
felt pretty awesome but I also think
that intuitively for me there was always
there was like a disconnect between the
stuff I was doing like I never imagined
myself at that serious because I was
just a kid and for me like the real
world I imagined it is so different
right so like the grown-ups making like
the computer work making airplanes work
write writing the software that people
actually use in real life I felt that
was like a separate world and what I was
doing was always gonna be only a toy so
it really took all the way until my
adult life where I started working for
like a real company and it's like okay
well the software they're doing isn't
really that different than the software
I'm doing like there's there's
definitely some tricks to make things
work better but you know there's no
disconnect like there's you know there's
a spectrum right of more and more
serious software and that's actually
something that I wish I knew more as a
kid of like you can really just you know
you can play at any league you want to
play em over some of those things that
you were building out you went to UC
Berkeley for computer science oh where
some of the things are building out
throughout your trajectory I'm sure yes
as a kid I just started with games so
like random games that were
that I didn't expect to have any impact
on the world just like you know trivia
games and like like I made a solitaire
game ride which was like no better than
any other saucer again but it's fun to
make and then in high school I made some
physics simulations so I'd learn a
concept like you know gravity and I'd
make a little simulation of a ball
falling by programming in the
acceleration so I was doing all that
stuff and you know nobody was really
using my software just like me making it
for myself and then it really took until
I got my first real job before I was
making software that was actually going
out in the world okay okay and so then
that was in what year was at mm doesn't
88 yeah Wow yeah I started working out
slide and I worked on a game called
super poke bets so I could give heard of
like throwing a sheep so that was a
company that made that and and you could
like take care of the sheep as your pet
so I was writing some of the code to
like buy stuff for your pet so it's
really not a very serious application
but it was my first exposure to you know
real people using stuff that I have you
know influence on and we did have like
millions of users okay so the code that
you were then deploying I had already
been at the scale of millions of people
using it exactly and and for me that's
something I really enjoy is you know I
could just be typing some code on a
computer and next thing you know we hit
the deploy button and you've got
millions of people right running it on
their own laptops so it's it's really a
pretty big influence it's kind of like
you're controlling a robot army right
and and so then I saw I guess I started
getting that sense of power yes yes okay
and then what about then with that since
power plus this passion for
entrepreneurship where how did that how
did those things collide for your
endeavor int quick C sure yeah so you
know I wanted to do something big and
interesting with my life right I wanted
to make an impact or just you know see
basically see what I could do right see
what the limit was of what kind of job I
could have or what kind of success I
could have so when I started quick C my
thought was like well yeah you know I've
heard of startups right I'd been reading
all about like
grams writing and following other people
startups and I was living in San
Francisco which is kind of like the
heart of the startup scene I was like
okay let's do this like it's possible to
just start a company and if you get
enough people using it you got enough
customers you got some investors you
could make the next Google right like
you could really you could change the
world basically rather you can make the
next big thing that that is a big part
of a lot of people's lives and kind of
be like just a big piece a big piece of
the world basically big new piece so
that was kind of the appeal of it to me
okay and then where did the idea for
what you wanted to build come from yeah
the idea of quick see my co-founder at
the time Tomer had the original idea and
he was saying well there's so many apps
coming out we just noticed there's a lot
of apps coming out and the the search
for the app in the App Store's was
horrible and all these developers were
basically getting shafted because they'd
work hard on an app they'd launch it and
they just got zero users mm-hmm and then
how would you guys drive more users -
yeah so it was a pretty vague idea but
the idea was basically like well we'll
just make a search engine so that on the
user side they just type anything and we
connect them to the right app instantly
right when it launches so we saw kind of
a marketplace failure so the vision was
to fix that mm-hmm
and then why then for people that were
going on to the Play Store onto the
Apple App Store
why would then people use quick see yeah
well I think you've pinpointed one of
the flaws in the model right as we
needed a whole distribution channel
right because if the user is accustomed
to going and searching in the Apple
Store why would they go out of their way
so we had a bunch of ideas for at a
various time so we explored everything
from like let's make an app on the users
home screen and the app is a better
search than their search bar or let's
integrate with maybe not Apple but like
with you know third-party operating
systems you know Google's Android
there's a lot of third-party Android
distributions let's integrate into the
search bar in that so we explored a
bunch of things but you have pinpointed
one of the the basic flaws in the
original model of click see and you know
it was ultimately clicks he failed so
and that was one of the flaws in general
pairing up
people that are seeking for the
information that they want more
effectively is really important so it's
yeah good that you guys were endeavoring
into trying to take on that grand
challenge and that includes things like
natural language processing which is
really hard if I type something into a
search bar if the parse and connect
those words to a catalog of apps that
also have those keywords that are linked
to them and this is tough computer
science for sure yeah yeah yeah I also
really liked what you guys did called
the quick C challenge which I thought
was really interesting I think it's so
applicable to the current market that
we're doing things like X prizes and
stuff like that so tell us about the
quick C challenge sure yeah so the the
quickie challenge was our solution to
the problem of just how do you find good
engineering talent because when you're
in the Bay Area it's it's really such a
scramble to get good engineering talent
there's so much competition and the
salaries are absolutely skyrocketing I
mean the the compensate just give you a
sense of the salary is it the
compensation package that an entry level
engineer can get here in 2019
it's literally three times like three
hundred percent of what I could get when
I was starting out ten years ago in 2009
so ten years triple the compensation
package that's insane right and like in
the mean time the average Americans
income has gone up like maybe ten
percent right it's barely moved compared
to three hundred percent so it's not
typical for this economy how valuable
programmers are becoming today it's it's
absolutely insane so in such a hard
market right so I was the quickly
challenged was more like in 2011-2012 so
it was just at the beginning of this
exponential growth and in programmer
competitiveness but we were just
thinking like look recruiters are
charging twenty percent of the
programmers first year salary and the
programmer is making six figures so
we're talking twenty grand even thirty
grand of recruiter commission so we just
ask ourselves well is there any way that
we can spend 20 grand more effectively
to get more than one good programmer and
so we came up with idea like well when
somebody's in college 20 grand is an
unthinkably high amount of money even a
hundred dollars is a lot of money for
you know a poor college student who
doesn't
yeah so why don't we just incentivize
people to you know give them something
to do for $100 so that was one of the
ideas and then we combine it with
another idea which is like hey when I'm
interviewing somebody to be a good
programmer I actually know a lot in the
first minute like I can actually you can
give me one minute and I'm already
pretty far along an interview like I
don't have a final decision but I could
probably start eliminating people in one
minute and maybe not one minute maybe
five minutes right but one minute is
like an exaggerated version of it so we
combine the ideas and we say let's give
them a one minute challenge where if
they succeed they get $100 and it's
lead-gen right it's lead generation for
our interview pipeline and it did in
fact work as expected it was a pretty
big success we hired like seven
candidates off of it we paid a lot less
than 20,000 per candidate we paid like
$5,000 per candidate all things equal so
we'd have to give out like maybe 50 of
these prizes but it also it really got
quick C's name out there when every
college student was like this is the
best way that I can make a hundred
dollars in one minute of my time so it
was kind of a hack that combined
together you know some elements of a
situation that is kind of an arbitrage
right like the $20,000 down to $100 yeah
yeah it's following a model that is
picking up a lot of steam this this
incentive model you come out and and
either you can crowdsource ideas and pay
people as a as a prize for the best
ideas that people are proud sourcing
anywhere from you know a hundred
thousand to a million dollars you can
also do things like filter for lead
generation for top talent in just a
hundred or five hundred or thousand
bucks and see if they can solve an
engineering challenge or see if they can
solve a design challenge or an OPS
challenge or a philosophy challenge
whatever it is nowadays and like you
said within a minute or five minutes so
how can you really refine an interview
process down to the most profound
questions that can give you the most
insight about if the candidate is best
and most right yeah efficient for for
the role so let's talk about the
transition then in 2017 to relationship
hero co-founder and CEO you guys were
part of Y Combinator summer 2017 batch
so why relationship
here Oh what is it and how did the idea
come up let's talk about it sure yeah so
relationship hero is a coaching service
a relationship coaching service so the
way you use it is whenever you have any
relationship issue whether it's you're
you don't know what to do on your date
you don't know what text your date you
don't know how to interpret a text
you're struggling in your relationship
you you don't know if you want to get
married you don't know if you want to
break up
you have broken up but you want to get
back together so any kind of
relationship issue that you have
we're basically your hotline 24/7 where
you can connect to a qualified certified
relationship coach who actually knows
what they're talking about who's talked
to thousands of people just like you who
has a playbook for your exact situation
and you can get you know very
personalized contextual help and you can
also schedule sessions you can you know
have like an hour-long session you can
learn stuff and apply that in your
relationship so that's the use case for
a relationship coach before relationship
hero that industry of relationship
coaching that segment of the market it
was virtually non-existent right it's
like can you name one famous
relationship coach or relationship
coaching company besides relationship
hero mmm mostly just yeah coaches that
are that work with one-on-one clients
that charge like a hundred bucks an hour
or whatever exactly right and they don't
really they're not necessarily
trustworthy if you know you might have
you might like try to go on Yelp to you
know to see if they're any good and you
know you have to schedule a physical
appointment so there was something very
weird about this industry because it was
like a tiny industry virtually
non-existent and then you look at how
many people need relationship coaching
you could probably list a few off the
top of your head right there's people
who are always talking to their friends
about their relationship problems and I
myself was somebody who needed
relationship coaching because I was
using a lot of dating apps right I was
using tinder Bumble OkCupid I was using
all these dating apps and I would see
this white screen and it would always
kind of SAP my energy looking at this
white screen because I'm like what the
hell am I supposed to say right I'm
trying to get the date like why can't I
just get the day why do I have to like
type stuff in a white screen where I
don't really care you know what I'm
saying I don't
character like randomly shoot the breeze
about you know a random sports or like
you know what do people talk about right
like interests animals just like have
these random conversations when I'm just
trying to get a date like what's going
on right so I was really failing to use
tinder or like understand how the
conversations are supposed to work so I
know what it's like to just want to get
a date or or want to you know have a
good conversation and just not know how
the game is played basically so that was
my own original experience where I'd go
to my co-founder Lior and I'd ask him to
help me out like hey what do I say and
him coaching me was the first spark
where I'm like maybe I'm not the only
guy in the world who is a little
confused in my dating life mm-hmm okay
so immediately there's this there's this
both a use case for yourself with your
own sort of realization that that
there's good there's gonna be a lot of
people around the world now we have
democratized information technology so
now we have the devices in our pockets
so it's much easier for us to connect
with a relationship coach across a
myriad of examples that you gave it can
be about the first message on the screen
or it can be about if you want to marry
the person or breakup with them or you
know maybe on your fifth date maybe it's
something else about intimacy or
something else about emotional relating
there's so many different ways that you
would be able to use a relationship
coach it's okay so you saw an important
market and you saw no one in the market
yet
right okay and so then you guys decided
to build a tech solution to solve this
okay so then now let's talk about how
you have about a hundred coaches right
now on the platform so available 24/7
that's right okay phone or messaging
exactly yeah okay so I can call in and
have a quick conversation I can just be
messaging back and forth this it's a via
an app
there it's actually you don't even have
to use our app you can visit our website
you can text us you can call us so it's
kind of like messaging a friend you know
you just you just send a message or call
it's a contact that I save in my phone
potentially like relationship your
contact that's that's probably the most
convenient way to use this is just text
us the same way or call us as you call a
friend yeah and then so then immediately
then you link me up with one of the
available coaches maybe I build a
relationship with maybe Sarah or
something and then it's not usually the
one that would come in and work with me
if she's available at the time that's
true but that said if it's an ongoing
situation most of our clients benefit
from having multiple coaches because
it's not like we're just a marketplace
that helps you find some other coach we
actually train and certify all the
coaches ourselves so we can guarantee
that if you're working with multiple
coaches you're still getting quality
consistent coaching so you're still you
know they're learning from the same
playbooks they're giving you compatible
advice and they're here for you 24/7
because you don't have to you know wake
the same coach up whenever you're awake
and they might be sleeping okay so all
of the coaches go through relationship
hero training so they all work with the
same playbook so you guys have developed
a proprietary playbook for exactly yeah
so not only do we notice a gap in the
market right so not only is there no
relationship coaching company besides
relationship hero if you look at
academia all right if you look at who's
researching what fields there's not
really a field of research for what we
call applied relationship skills you
know no saying so so that you'll have
psychologists right you'll have people
researching into mental health but you
don't have people researching hey what
is the most effective tactic to restore
a breakup you said I'm saying it's an
applied science
nobody's researching it so we
simultaneous got to be like okay let's
have people in our company essentially
do the research and write up these
guides and test them and then other
people in our company you know be the
coaches let's do both let's do the
research and also the commercial
application mm-hmm so out of the myriad
of social dynamics that exists the
social situations you are building out a
catalog a day
base of the of the possibilities the
approaches that you can take to each one
let's say you know type a is to restore
the breakup like you were saying maybe
type B is the first date that type of
thing and so let's say for type B on the
first date you have you know option A
through option Q or whatever of the
different approaches that you can take
in their efficacy levels so other
success levels but then there's always
different psychometric profiles with for
the people so maybe one person wants you
to come in aggressively and ask for the
first date person wants you to talk more
about their cat before you ask them on
the first date so how do you guys do you
guys have any machine learning that
you're putting into play here to be able
to figure out if option option M is
working really well for a specific
psychometric profile and so you're
running these patterns and you're
analyzing them to optimize yes so right
now we don't have AI doing any of the
actual coaching like so it's all like
human wisdom basically and the kind of
insights we get are like well we we had
this playbook and we tried it on a bunch
of clients and we had this hypothesis
and it hasn't been proven out 80 percent
of the time so it's more like humans
doing science more like that then like
oh the Machine figured everything out
and here it just spits out the solution
and just take it because it's optimal so
it's not like that we actually think
that in terms of what AI can do there's
a lot of fields where I can come in and
start replacing humans but relationship
coaching is a relatively hard problem
for AI a lot of the most subtle things
about human interaction are our
relationships right like a romantic
relationship is a very complicated dance
a lot of the intelligence that's in the
human brain is dedicated to that those
social skills so you know it's gonna be
one of the last things that computers
figure out how to do better than us mmm
okay interpersonal dynamics the nuance
of social communication okay yeah yeah
okay yeah yeah that's been that's been
up there in one of the last frontiers of
of super intelligence of general
intelligence okay so okay so then let's
talk about the different like
combinatorics that occur cuz I think a
lot of people are experiencing stuff
that's in the same domain as what you
were explaining about your own issue
yeah that you had okay so you have this
blank screen and you don't know what the
first message
there's obviously again this word
combinatoric so you can message
something how are you you can manage
hello you can message a smiley face hey
what are you doing more possible
conversations than grains of sand on all
of each is exactly so then what is most
effective as the first message yeah so
if you're just sending a cold message to
somebody the first message you want to
get their interest you want ideally
spark a positive emotion and then you
want to make it easy and fun for them to
reply right because I mean think about
what you want right these are all
directly related to your goals right
your goal is basically to see if you're
compatible and to see if you guys can
have a good interaction together so this
is basically you manufacturing the thing
that you want if you want a good
conversation well say something that
right off the bat sparks a good reaction
from their side it's a good conversation
so one thing that's usually good and the
first message is to include some kind of
compliment you know a genuine compliment
and it doesn't have to be like a
brilliantly inspired poetic compliment
it can literally just be like I like
your pics it's like four words but you
throw that in and then you you throw in
something else that maybe you've
observed about their profile which gets
their interest it's nice if the she has
a photo with a dog you might want to say
that's a great picture of you with your
dogs exactly it's a great picture with
your dog and then if you ask a question
that's like specific to your dog like
you know how do you clean up all the
shedding or whatever I mean that might
you know maybe that's not the most
interesting or do you like going with
your dog you know stuff like that would
yeah where do you like going
and then now that's a good start but I
would tweak that question a little bit
because because that gets the last
criterion which is you want it to be
easy and fun to answer mm-hmm so the
problem with where do you like going is
it's it's what I call a nonspecific
question so no it leaves so many
possible answers it's harder for them to
reply but exactly so the problem with
that question and this is very subtle
and I've never seen this tightening
anywhere else but we teach it out
relationship hero which is in order for
the girl you're messaging to answer that
question she basically has to give you a
specific answer so she starts having to
give you specific detail from your life
like well I like to go to a dog park and
there's like a section with small dogs
that he likes to play with so you're
expecting a specific detail answer but
you yourself didn't provide much
specific detail and your question so
that is actually a hint that you're
sending a bad message if you're
expecting more specificity out of the
reply than you're providing interest
yeah and it's related to a concept in
improvisational theater you know improv
where if you're a character on an improv
it's kind of weak to be like what are we
doing right where it's stronger to be
like hey you know mix in some more
chocolate for our for this candy bar you
know like it's it's considered good
improv to be like throwing in detail and
painting the scene compared to just
putting the burden on the other person
to paint the same so there's something
analogous if you're trying to
manufacture a good conversation and on a
dating app you should really provide a
lot of specific details that the other
person can work with so we can tweak
that question and we can be like hey
your dog looks pretty small do you have
to stay you have to stay with the small
dog area and the dog park because
suddenly you're like being so specific
with your question and then another
personal deck I know sometimes you can
play with bigger dogs and suddenly the
conversation it feels like it has this
momentum and the secret to that is the
specificity okay okay
I like the comparison here to what is
known from improvisational theater
because I myself really enjoyed my time
in in debate and in
speech and improv practices those are
super duper fun exactly and even doing
stand-up comedy these are very important
things to practice in life and so this
one's super relatable I think for a lot
of us is especially those that like to
practice humor is you can be like why
don't you wear your rainbow socks today
then you'll be like because my rainbow
socks are in the washing machine or
whatever and so you know I'm we're
opening up a conversation and a fun
dialectic manner rather than maybe
closing it off right away with a very
very specific question okay okay so then
what would then a what like let's go
again with some of the higher like
efficacy strategies for those first
moments you know you said you want to
make it relatable you want to make it
easy to reply to you want to make them
feel like they're having fun
yep yep you want and it is kind of funny
because it is I mean look for the the
way the way we teach it I mean I used
the word manufacture like you want to
manufacture a good conversation you want
to contrive a good conversation but it's
still better than saying something lame
you know what I'm saying so like I I
might sometimes back when I was dating I
might send a text that it took me like
10 minutes to think of the perfect text
but when the other person reads it right
the reaction they get is like oh this
conversation is so fun and spontaneous
oh right and and when I say it now it's
like wow like it almost sounds like I'm
a creep right well I don't think I'm a
creep because like look at stand-up
comedy right like the stand-up comic
it's like he he looks really cool right
if you watch a stand-up comic but the
stuff he's telling you is like so
memorized right like the most casual
gesture he makes it so memorized so
there's some times when your best
strategy is to be a little contrived
right to give the other person that
spontaneous feeling and I think one of
those times is you know the beginning of
online dating if there's somebody that
you really like you really want to
maximize your chance with them then I
think that you should think hard and and
send them a text that you work hard on
even if
it comes off as casual mm-hmm it's a
really good comparison to even the
smallest gestures and the stand-up
routines or have been have had hours and
hours of practice to make them for the
audience make them feel like it's a
spontaneous exactly you're laughing like
he you know a lot of times the stand-up
comic you'll think that he just thought
of it and it's really secretly part of
his routine so the reason the stand-up
comic a good stand-up comic drills what
he's saying like crazy the reason is
because it's high-stakes right if you
want to be at the top of your game and
be like you know a stand-up comic is
drawing crowds you know you better have
the best routine you have and similarly
with texting if you only give yourself
five seconds to toss off every text you
know you could be decent right you get a
but you're just not going to be as good
as if you like you know give it your
best shot and take a little more time
okay so let's say again we have some
maybe a picture of her that's you know
hiking maybe on a nice trail or
something with a nice sunset view or
whatnot yeah so what do we say in the in
the first message definitely so I'd
throw in something like I like your pics
or any compliment and the reason is
because and you know imagining a guy
talking to a girl hypothetically so the
reason is just because you get a
compliment it's like no you know
everybody likes compliments and just as
a little tangent a lot of guys are like
oh don't compliment too much because
then you come off neat that's actually
not true coming off needy is bad and a
lot of the guys will compliment in a
needy way but as long as you're just
genuinely giving a compliment and
there's enough other things you're doing
that aren't needy then it's perfect
because who doesn't like getting a
compliment right comments are great so
you start with a compliment and then you
throw in so you mentioned like hiking on
a trail and there's a sunset so the key
to that you know most people would ask a
generic question right just like where
are you hiking
where was that hiked yeah exactly which
is it breaks the rule of like oh so you
want them to tell you something specific
and you just ask where that's not fair
that's not gonna make for a good
conversation you're you're actually
killing the momentum when you do that
okay so the key is what can we inject
where we're bringing specificity that
wasn't there already so like some random
specific thing that might have to do
with like hiking on a trail so let's
think about that
let's see a random split basically think
about improv right
imagine you're doing an improv or hiking
on a trail like basically some random
thing has to happen to make the scene
interesting okay so go ahead so I'm just
thinking like so what other stuff can
you do when you're hiking on a trail and
it's the sunset okay okay so there's
something about maybe the trees or there
something or anything like just a random
idea I had is like a climb that tree in
the picture before or sure I mean that
if you can actually have climb a tree in
the picture before I mean if you really
have sure that could be interesting but
but even if you say that I would
probably mention some specific detail
like I like how there's like this fat
branch on the back you know I've climbed
that but that's that's not really
plausible but that would be like the
kind of thing where you're bringing
specificity you're talking about the fat
branch another idea I just had is like
so what kind of trail mix are you
packing checks you know we're here
you're just like really specifically
asking about the trail mix it's a nice
party what kind of trail mix are you
packing exactly because the thing about
it is you've already given her the
compliment right so she's already you
know flattered and now the question it's
a ridiculous question but it's easy and
fun to answer yeah she's just like oh
yeah she's just like I don't pack trail
mix on my hikes I pack fruit yeah
exactly she's like I was eating a banna
and then you talk about the banana and
it's like what would you say back to the
Buddha if she's like I only like to eat
a banana
um I then I might say like is it organic
or or do you go for you know the are you
okay with GMO like I just say that
because it's a specific way like here's
the thing she's not gonna delete the
conversation right she's gonna give you
the answer you know I'm saying so okay
so you're adding specificity and leaving
her with more open or not to open but
kind of actually more closed well answer
the the thing is it's more like I'm
creating momentum you're creating
momentum that's what you've been saying
good right because when she's reading
these texts she's thinking like this is
ridiculous but let me just start typing
funny she's getting bigger she's gonna
start typing the answer okay and then
you go but organic or GMO and she says
organic
yeah show Beco I only eat organic then
what do you say um so I don't want to
like go down a rabbit hole of the banana
right but now the thing is I've already
accomplished my objective of starting
the momentum now we have momentum but
now what maybe you ask a new question
that's yeah with this momentum yeah and
there's other things I could do so if
she's like I only eat organic I know a
good organic restaurant maybe we should
go sometime I that's so that that brings
in other concepts which is I think
what's the other concept that we just so
that's that's another mistake most guys
make is they'll like get like a little
bit of rapport right we're like there's
something and I was like yeah and
they're like I know let's go back I know
got this nailed here so this is another
principle we teach which is like look if
you're a guy talking to a girl girls get
a lot of matches and so if you're
inviting her out on a date right away
that will work if she's already very
attracted to you so like let's say that
the girls would meet your pictures and
she's thinking like oh this guy's my
type you know he's got a dog I like dogs
so if the girls already sold on you then
find no problem yeah but a more common
situation is that the girl's not sold on
you yet and the conversation you're
having is a big part of how she's gonna
get sold on you yes so if you just have
like one little thing where you both
have a dog and then you ask her out the
problem is you know she's got a hundred
other guys where they also have one
little thing right so she could be like
so she might be like yeah sure let's go
on a date and that's where you got the
flake right so you got a lot of girls
flaking and that's that's a big problem
today as girls will flake so if you want
to have a non flaky date you really have
to show or why you're actually a better
you know date it's you're a better
investment for a right because you want
her to get ready for the day you want
her to come out on the date you know
there's a safety issue right she's
meeting a stranger a guy that she's
never met before she has to go to a
location she might be tired for right
she has to like you know put her makeup
on change for the date right so you're
asking so much of her and all you've
given her is like you know nice banana
right that's good it's just not enough
there's an asymmetry like she's seen
your pictures she's seen you say like a
couple of good message it's not enough
for her to make a big investment okay so
having maybe
a couple days of back-and-forth
conversation where she feels like you're
witty and you're also her type and all
this other kind of additional
information could yeah could really up
your chances yeah I mean so the main
takeaway is I mean the thing is whatever
you're hoping to accomplish on the day
right you want to feel each other out
and show each other that you have a good
time the thing is you can actually start
doing a lot of that over the text like
you can you can basically you can get
extra credit you can you can accomplish
more than most people accomplish like
most people just think that they can do
nothing on text and they have the game
begins when you meet in person mm-hmm
but really you can start getting pretty
far over text I mean some people have
entire online relationships I'm not
saying that you should go do that but I
am saying that like whatever charm you
were gonna show on the day just start
showing it over text it's the same time
so I really appreciate him we were
talking before we started we were
talking about the importance of altering
people's life trajectories so this is
very interesting it's about now that we
have the information technology at our
fingertips and we can do something like
it a dating coach just on-demand there's
actually a greater potential for us to
find someone that we may be aligned
without a deeper level intellectually
emotionally spiritually physically etc
and so for me to invest a little bit
more time into looking maybe outside of
my you know immediate what used to be
just village and now we can look so much
further for more diversity in genetics
and that seems to be something that is a
big driver of people coming together to
form a biological swirl as you're like
offspring of your child so okay so then
now if we do invest a little bit more
time into doing something like getting a
relationship coach and we nail the first
maybe 50 messages which span over three
days and that keep them engaged and
they're super pumped to go out with you
that then you have a greater likelihood
of
potentially landing a better more
aligned partner that for for your life
and for ya maybe who you end up marrying
and having a child with so this is the
big this is the big deal is altering
people's life trajectories towards
better matches yeah I mean I think what
we were talking about how it's it's high
stakes so when you use a dating app you
know they have you're just swiping and
it's very tempting to treat it like I
don't really care about this you know
I'm just bored I'm waiting in line so
I'm just taking this out and swiping
it's like stop digging around and take
this seriously because if you're in your
20s right now right you're you're
eventually gonna get married you're
gonna have kids so you you kind of only
have one shot to find the right partner
right hits like a it's a big freakin
deal it's I mean if you have to put a
price on it you know it's on the order
of like a million dollars it's a million
dollars right so are you really going to
pretend that it's like casual to just
open it up and swipe people because you
know with if you're in your 20s or if
you're single chances are within the
next few years you're gonna be making a
huge life decision as to who you're
gonna date so when you're busting out
that up and when you're typing stuff
with your thumbs it might feel casual
but I think you should you should give
it the seriousness that it deserves yeah
this is a this is a very interesting
perspective there's people that come on
with the intention of just these desires
for like one-night stands the whole
Netflix and chill culture and then there
is also this like very serious
especially with like OkCupid and so
there seems to be more of a drive
towards they were bumble the more of a
drive towards like serious dating
yeah I'm rather than hookup culture on
tan tan or tinder and stuff like that so
then okay so then if you do come in with
that intent of having this be more about
like serious dating and identifying life
partners this type of stuff then every
single message is actually
mission-critical but then we also have
to remember that especially like let's
just take let's just take an example
right let's take an example like let's
just throw me into the mix that you know
if I'm trying to build a company and I'm
also trying to go on some days how do I
decide to invest tens of minutes into
drafting these men
yep when I don't even know if these
people are gonna go on dates with me
and then I also I'm trying to build a
company and climb up the hierarchy and
become a better and better mate for
these potential partners so yeah what
are your thoughts about that so you have
you have a certain amount of resources
that you can invest into you know
attracting then finding a quality mate
you have a certain amount of total
resources and let's say in terms of time
let's say you have two hours a week that
you can devote toward dating total which
is not very much time if you're serious
about doing it you probably need more
time than that but even if you only have
two hours a week it's like okay so you
can argue only off two hours a week so I
don't have time to be like spending 10
minutes on a message but I mean what's
the alternative
hey what how do you do it without
spending the time maybe the alternative
is something like like really focusing
on like self work and becoming a better
and better mate that's higher and higher
up on the hierarchy and then it becomes
a little bit easier and easier to
attract candidates for dates and then
you're not chasing but rather people are
coming to you sure yeah so you know it's
definitely a lot of people will prefer
you know richer mate right so if you're
working hard at your career and suddenly
you know your income goes up
significantly that is gonna you know
that's gonna help and your dating life
right if you're going on a date and
you're able to you know buy as many
drinks as you need you know go out to
nice meals like it's no problem that's
definitely a strength if you can do that
and you know for for both sexes if you
have a nice apartment or a home that
ever it is to bring your date back to
this is also a huge deal this is a big
deal across the world as well we just
came back from doing partnership
interviews in China and this is a big
deal for a mate for the man to have a
piece of real estate don't lie it's a
huge deal and grandparents are funneling
money into their child to have yes a
property to become a better choice for
me so there's all these different pieces
so the key here is ROI return on invest
right what do you have to spend and what
do you get back so let's say that you're
you're like fresh out of college and the
best job you can get is paying you forty
thousand dollars a year so if you let's
say you go to a coding bootcamp right
and it's like a six-month coding
bootcamp and by the end it can teach you
to make six figures right so it can more
than double your income for three months
well that's probably a good investment
for your own life as well as for your
dating right that's that's just a great
ROI it's a great return on investment
now let's say that you you just hate
computer programming you don't have
access to a programming bootcamp so that
path is closed to you and you're making
$40,000 a year and you wish you could
make more but you just don't really have
a reliable way to make more fast like
maybe you can work overtime you can bust
your ass and you can make you know fifty
thousand instead of 40,000 but then you
have like no time so you're not gonna
get a high ROI trying to increase your
income but if you work on your text
messages right if you spend a few extra
minutes a day on your text message that
could significantly that could actually
increase the number of quality dates you
get by like fifty percent right okay
interesting so if you find yourself
maybe closer to like let's say the
middle of a financial hierarchy and you
don't see yourself with a lot of upward
movement that if you work on investing
maybe a dozen or more hours into your
messaging game you can potentially
procure a higher level mates okay okay
there's so many strategies right and you
just you just want to see what strategy
is gonna get me the biggest results the
fastest if you're somebody who if you're
a very outgoing guy right and and you
look good maybe you know maybe if you've
been working out you got muscles maybe
what you should do is you know hit the
bars right hit the bar seen and and and
chat people up right that might be your
best strategy and forget about texting
and entirely work on chatting and
in-person and that's an impertinence
in person ammok yeah yeah versus though
yeah the message right now if you're an
introvert and you're going to bars and
you're trying to get better at talking
to people I've bars my advice would be
write it off just accept that you're not
good at talking to people the same way
as like a person who doesn't have a path
to a higher income it's like okay don't
worry about the income or don't worry
about being attractive at bars just
accept that you're gonna be in the
the room nursing your drink and not
talking to anybody and that's gonna end
talking to your friends and then you go
home but you're a monster on tinder
that's okay you're right it's okay to
just play to your strengths
yeah yeah okay okay yeah I like all
these different aspects that were
combining or combining socioeconomics
with the biology and hierarchies along
with time constraints along with social
sociability and the information
technology so it's actually interesting
relationship hero kind of incorporates
all of those fields together and so
really there's there's got to be a
really good amount of thought that goes
not only behind someone that's aiming to
get into the dating scene to know
themselves but also for when they do
decide to use a platform to know like
relationship hero when they figure out
okay well what kind of what kind of what
kind of advice am I even looking for
from a relationship coach then how are
they gonna help me with what I'm trying
to achieve with my dating game so you
got a-you know go in knowing about but
then like you said you guys also have
you know you're going through all of
these countless you're doing you're
making hypotheses and you're testing
them about what is most effective which
i think is also really interesting
that's super interesting data
you guys are developing a big amount of
interesting data and so for me yeah for
you guys to be able to run really strong
analysis on that data pattern
recognition on that data and and figure
out what could further optimize people's
success will then make more
recommendations for you yeah referrals
from people towards you interesting
and so relationship hero is a free
download but then it costs money to use
yeah exactly yeah so you basically pay
for the coaches time paper usage so you
could buy for example like a pack of
four hours worth of coaching credits and
they never
expire so you can just get coaching
anytime until you've had four hours then
you gotta buy more credits what are the
increments in terms of committee do I
can only use an hour at a time or
cuttings 30 minutes at a time that's
this yes increment there are actually no
small segments so just very flexible and
you can just come and go you can get
five minutes at a time where we're here
for you you know it's a modern
convenient method okay so I can just I
can just uh mmm I can just even text
into the to the relationship hero number
and then just say you know here's my
screenshot of my context one screenshot
yeah and I'm getting a reply saying but
hey try this message see what happens
yeah that could work
okay stuff like that and then that maybe
cost me three or five minutes exact a
little budget that I have of four hours
exactly okay yep now the coaches three
minutes is gonna be a lot more effective
most likely unless you're really good at
this
getting the coaches three minutes is
probably gonna get you a better result
than you spending even ten minutes on it
which again is really interesting we
were talking about the amount of time
that if you're trying to build a company
in climbed hierarchy well why not in
this case outsource some of this to
science into interpersonal relationship
analysis and so just feed that data in
try and learn from it as you're you know
feeding it in and and then increase your
efficacy at the same time yeah exactly
and if you're trying to play to your
strengths there's a lot of people who
are like uncomfortable on a date when
I'm talking with a person I'm
uncomfortable texting so should you
invest in teaching yourself to be
comfortable texting or should you just
use your money right to pay a coach to
advise you as to what to text and then
you get into your comfort zone because
once you get on the date that's really
where you're already really good and you
really you know you really click with
the person in real life and so it's all
about using your strengths and then just
kind of having somebody else compensate
for your weakness I mean that's a good
strategy to how to be successful totally
you know you know you keep coming again
to the know thyself yeah if you're best
in person follow strategy like that yeah
okay so this is great so this is all
on relationship hero and again
relationship eurocom so those I want to
give it a go give it a go tell your
friends people online about it get
talking about it that's be using it it's
a very interesting to hear about let us
know your thoughts in the comments also
about how it's going with you and using
the platform later on let's talk about
also your interest in two organizations
that you're an advisor for the machine
intelligence Research Institute and also
Center for Applied rationality and tell
us about this has been a long time both
you've been involved with for seven
years it's a long time so why did you
get involved in those two and yeah let's
start with that why sure yes I've
actually been very interested back since
back in 2007 even before those
organizations existed I was reading
overcoming bias which was a blog about
rationality and then less wrong calm and
I was spending a lot of time with some
the pioneers of the modern rationality
movement basically and what it appealed
to me is just it basically helps you
clarify your thinking right so there's a
bunch of people out in the world trying
to think smartly right trying to do
science trying to build stuff trying to
you know learn about themselves so
everybody's trying to be smart but our
brains weren't really made by evolution
to necessarily be that good at thinking
they were made to be that good at like
arguing with each other fighting going
to war right having sex right so the
brains we have aren't really designed to
think that well unless it's for specific
applications so it's kind of like
thinking really well it's a little bit
like trying to play the piano with your
foot it's like yes you have toes you can
use your toes to hit the keys but your
foot is not really like a general you
know manipulator of keys it's more like
it's good for walking you don't think so
that's kind of like using your brain
it's using your brain to try to like
figure out you know what's the nature of
reality you can learn it but it just
takes training right so the thing that
appeals to me about the Center for
Applied rationality and machine
intelligence
Institute is their whole reason for
being is to work on how to break down
these problems like the Center for
Applied rationality it's like what's the
best way for two humans to arrive at at
a correct like to disagree and arrive at
a consensus to go from a disagreement to
a consensus you know because that should
be possible a lot better than people do
it on Twitter so they're researching
that or like machine intelligence
Research Institute they're researching
the question of like well machines are
gonna get smart so how do we make sure
that machines who are smarter than us
are still doing stuff that we want them
to do because once they're smarter than
us if they weren't programmed right to
begin with there's not necessarily an
off button at that point okay so start
with the first example you gave how do
we have better conversations sure yeah
which you cave this example of Twitter
which is war which is literally the one
of the worst I just it's just becoming
more and more evident that the social
platforms are polarizing they have echo
chambers they're based on non nuanced
thinking binary thinking cognitive ease
tribalism I mean it's just endless the
business plans are tied to the attention
economy there's so many issues with
those platforms and there's even when
you do do something like meet in person
with someone to have the in-person
conversation that's usually gonna be a
much easier place for you to do
something like list out the you know
steel man list out the person's thoughts
about a topic like healthcare and then
you list out your points about
healthcare and you try and find the
nuance and you know this type of stuff
sure yeah so you mentioned steel Manning
like that's the opposite of straw
Manning right was where you somebody
says something and you think that their
arguments a little weak but you help
them out and you give a stronger version
of their own argument and sometimes
they'll agree that that's really what
they meant and sometimes they'll they'll
switch to you're still man and and
that's like that's considered you know
good form when you're arguing with
somebody in your trying
arguments the strongest version of their
beliefs and that doesn't happen very
much on Twitter because Twitter is all
about you know hitting somebody with a
zinger right you hit them with a zinger
and then you just ignore them right and
that's like a good strategy on Twitter
because you can get a lot of likes on
your zinger and then if you ignore them
it's like who cares because you don't
you can just leave the game read and so
Twitter doesn't encourage you know the
kind of good rational debate that the
Center for Applied rationality is trying
to encourage and in addition to steel
Manning they give you a few other tools
that are really useful so one of them is
called double crux which is a tool when
you're arguing with somebody where it's
related to what we were talking about
before the taping which is if you and I
are arguing I can actually give you
what's called the crux of my
disagreement which is like this is the
thing I currently believe where if I
could just change my mind on that then
I'd stop disagreeing with you and then
you can focus on convincing me of the
crux whereas most people come into an
argument like it's a battlefield and
it's like I just have a bunch of weapons
to shoot at you and everything you say
at me I want to like slap down whereas
I'm like no no this is my Achilles heel
it's right here here's my Achilles heel
if you want to shoot an arrow that thing
I welcome it because if you change it
I'll change my mind and then we'll agree
and then you do the same thing to me you
tell me how I can change your mind
and if we both do that and we're both
focused on kind of flipping the other
person's crux that becomes a more
productive you know it's that's like a
path toward an agreement and in theory
there's this thing called omens
agreement theorem in it's a theorem of I
think Bayesian probability and it's a
theorem of like if you have two
artificial intelligences two intelligent
agents that have disagreeing beliefs
there should be a process where they can
share their disagreement and and arrive
at a consensus belief like there's no
reason why two people who come in with a
disagreement can't walk out with a
shared reality you know that should in
theory be possible yes unless the
rationality is coming from the organ of
the brain which is very more more
difficult than AI agents that are based
on computer logic yeah well so there's
there's a lot of problems with the human
brain that make it not
yeah it's emotions and it's also just
the fact that like I might believe
something because I've gained a lot of
intuitions about it you know what I'm
saying so like imagine a firefighter
who's done 30 years of firefighting they
could be like I don't know why I believe
this but I think this house isn't safe
right now I can't tell you why it looks
like everything about it is safe but I
think we should exit the house right now
hmm
and a lot of times it'll be right and
the house collapses and like I don't
know how I knew that so these kind of a
lot of times your brain will have a
belief that it's built up and you can't
just
you can't give a full data dump of why
that belief exists in your brain and
that's one of the confounders of trying
to do the perfect omens agreement
theorem between two humans AI agents
don't have intuition quite yet so it's
not that they don't have intuition
agents might have complex like if I
build a super intelligent artificial
intelligence it might have quote-unquote
intuition built out of all the complex
data its processing yes but it can give
you a memory dump right so the human
brain
I can't plug in a flash drive into my
brain and get a full readout of what's
in my brain that's the problem mm-hmm
yeah it's it's very difficult to take my
my top three points on on health care or
geopolitics and for me to just be able
to like recite them at any time yeah not
only recite the points but recite the
whole mental structure that makes you
believe the point if I say why you
believe this you might give me a couple
of reasons
and I might even slap down the reasons
to some degree in Quebec well I don't
think you slap down everything I still
think I believe this for some reason
and you might have a good reason like
the firefighter right and one day we'll
be able to scan your brain and actually
you know and actually report what's
going on in your brain the structure of
your belief and we'll be like okay it
looks like you actually do have like a
well trained neuron model of like one
houses breakdown even though you
couldn't put it into words so one day
you'll be able to do that and certainly
any artificial intelligence will be able
to do that because the building blocks
that we make the artificial intelligence
out of the building blocks will be like
we'll use like you know flash memory
right and we'll just use components that
are easily dumped like a neuron just
doesn't have a flashdrive interface the
way a computer does there's proposals
for this chemo electro connecting which
I think are so fascinating
seeing if you can actually identify like
your belief on geopolitics with the
specific array of a thousand or 10,000
neurons sharing their connections and
the neural transmission happening
between them this is very interesting
I like how you also mentioned the
Achilles heel I think that was a very
interesting point going into the
conversations you should expose your own
Achilles heel intentionally I mean if
your goal if you're if you're trying to
do rhetoric right if your goal is to win
the debate and impress an audience well
then just give them great sound bites
right it's like we're not I can't give
you the ultimate techniques for that
because that's not what I care about my
goal is to walk away with the best
beliefs right so if I'm walking into an
argument and I am in fact wrong the best
thing that can happen to me an argument
is to lose you know saying because it's
actually winning in terms of improving
my beliefs changing your mind can be
winning and that's a very important
thing that many people can better embody
that's a good one exactly there's a
there's a nice pithy saying about it
which is not every change is an
improvement but every improvement is a
change mmm so there's clearly a lot of
improvements that I can make between my
current mental state and the mental
state where I only believe a bunch of
true things like there's clearly a bunch
of changes that I can make I don't know
exactly what the changes are but every
time I go into discussion I'm open to
making the changes mm-hmm yeah good may
be a good example for the Securities
heal would be something along the lines
of like maybe say like hey I'm you know
I'm open I'm open to the concept of an
idea of basic income just show me how it
would help people continue to find deep
meaning and purpose in their day to day
life kind of okay let me let me come up
with my points around exactly that to
help you yeah and you might say
something like look this is this is my
sticking point this is my crocks if you
were to slap down my cracks or change my
belief about my crux at that point my
overall view would shift from being anti
to not sure and then if you flip this
other thing I might go from not sure to
being pro so you can even say like it's
kind of like painting targets on
yourself like hey if you knock down this
target this is the effect it will have
on my belief
mm-hmm yes yes the art of outstanding
conversations and of nuance driven
conversations and of being receptive to
changing one's mind and for the future
of taking these memory dumps I think is
very very interesting as well at times
these three thousand are more now
Evernote files that I have are trying to
figure out a way maybe to do something
like making memory dump and then parse
them for key points and then make
knowledge graphs and turn them into
movies and TV shows and books and all
this different kind of stuff and so this
is all very interesting how can we take
the top you know one percent of of
information that you're currently
storing in your memory and how can we
visualize that information and in your
world view how can we actually visualize
your world view right now and in all
these little like Achilles heels and
your top points all this type of stuff
okay yeah there's a lot of important
dynamics that go into this art of
outstanding conversation I like how how
how you find it to be such an important
thing it is as questions are a way to
probe reality and there are a way to
have really good nuanced dialogue with
each other dog meant our world views and
so it's very very important to know how
to have that functioning quite well in
one's life yeah I like smarter and I
think the key is just to understand like
the brain you know again we're
repurposing it to be this truth seeking
instrument like evolution didn't give a
crap about whether your beliefs were
true about the universe like there's
nothing in your brain that makes it
natural to go and discover you know that
that's time and space is
four-dimensional and that actually
causes gravity you know like Einstein's
general relativity there's nothing in
the human brain that gives a crap about
general relativity that was basically us
going way off course and like and just
being like you know taking our foot and
be like I'm gonna play the piano this
you don't say
it's like if I do a bunch of toe
exercises I can start playing the piano
with my foot it's just not what the foot
is designed were right
the brain is not designed to go learn
general relativity that was like very
much like a bonus that we repurpose it
for mm-hmm interesting so the nervous
system itself just being purposed for
having parsing environments for the most
important stimuli and then related to
reproduction and food it's an original
right the foot is an organ for walking
right the brain is an organ for winning
arguments having sex hunting you know
I'm saying like that's what the organ is
for the there was never it's not like
our ancestors learned about general
relativity and that's why they're you
know the smarter ones survived it was
just it's just a bonus right like I
could play the piano a little bit with
my feet right but that's not what my
foot is for it hmm interesting so all of
these complex conversations that we are
having with each other about political
philosophy maybe the brain wasn't
actually so the brain was designed to
play politics right but politics in a
hunter-gatherer tribal in the brain
evolved the politic was like hey should
we go and is this person committing
treason to the tribe is this person
being too selfish should we go and steal
back some of his meat that he hunted
should he share more of the meat with
these other families or like hey this
guy should should he really be allowed
to marry this girl should we kill him
should we banish him from the tribe
should we send him off to war so these
are all actually politics so you know
humans are a social species you don't
have loner humans right they all depend
on all the other humans in their tribe
but our scales are you getting to our
scales oh well if you're talking about
yeah National Park the fact that we're
all interested in national politics is
definitely a very weird situation to be
in a special unit because we have so
little influence about it so I agree
like you are seeing a disconnect where
we all think that tribal politics is so
important because it really is when
there is you know 50 people in your
tribe gossiping about every little thing
that's going on is actually important
and you can actually influence it now
when there's 50 people in the White
House and and and then there's 300
million people gossiping about it
that is just a huge waste of energy and
like a very disproportionate use of
energy so that's definitely a pretty
messed up situation we're living in okay
so the the so it's almost as though over
time the brains involvement with it's
the brains involvement in political
philosophy was initially as we were
evolving as a species more about our
tribe and more about the small nuance
within that and now having eight billion
humans and exponential technologies and
all those types of things we're way out
of proportion with our scales and we're
also trying to do you know the marriage
of quantum mechanics and general
relativity we're trying to to understand
the ultimate nature of reality and with
the creation of this universe is even
for and so these things are just like
way different than resource allocation
within a tribe so yeah give Johnny two
apples and saira.3 when you think about
politics as like the human mind thinks
that all politics is office politics
right so like think about like the petty
crap like who gets access to the fridge
you know saying like all of that stuff
or like oh this guy's project is getting
promoted because he's close with the
boss like those little things that used
to just be the same thing as politics
again in the scale of like the office or
in the try exactly yeah anything past
that is already like really separating
our from the brain quite far again like
the toes playing the the p.m. ya know
exactly it's it's a weird situation to
be an interesting I like I like thus
analogy of the the brain kind of being
thrown at all these different things
when the use case of the function right
it's so much more limited than all these
additional right and there's so many
people are like oh listen your brain
knows the answer it's like really does
my foot know how to play the piano
because it's if you there's a
fundamental mismatch right between the
is that we're trying to think about
today and what our brain is designed to
do so we should all realize that it's
we're in a weird situation and if you
want to thrive in a weird situation you
need to do weird techniques so for
example for Aalto pianists we better all
start doing really hardcore hardcore toe
exercises right that is how to thrive in
the world where everybody's playing the
piano with their toes and that's what's
going on here so like you can't you
can't expect to like intuitively know
the answer it's so bring it back to
relationship hero everybody's like
listen to your heart well does your
heart really know about like you know
relationships and in the modern world
right where you can like move around a
lot and you know there's everybody's on
their phones and there's it's not like
there's no arranged marriages right
you're like everybody's funding for
themselves and people are flaky it's
like does your heart really know all
that stuff there's a lot of variables to
calculate yeah it does your heart how
well does your heart know information
technology exactly yeah yeah yeah you
know okay now like this has been
interesting how about the on the machine
tells us research institute what are
your thoughts about building super
intelligence that's aligned with
maximizing prosperity and decreasing
existential risk sure yeah so I mean the
thing is once you start talking about
super intelligence it's it's just very
it's what we call sensitive to initial
conditions because the thing is once you
once you get the first super
intelligence going it's just it has such
a big impact on the future it's like
everything else you want to know about
the future we'll come back to the
question of like well how did the first
super intelligence or super
intelligences get going what were their
initial conditions because if you know
if an evil genius was hell-bent on
destroying humanity and so he programmed
the first super intelligence to destroy
humanity by making nanotechnology that
just eats through the whole earth and
then we're dead
right like that would definitely
determine the future of humanity is the
fact that somebody pulled that off so
it's kind of like the whole the whole
evolution of the future is being
squeezed through this very narrow this
narrow future outcome of like what's
going on with the initial conditions of
super intelligence so you asked about
you know saving humanity and you know
making making people thrive solving a
lot of our problems that's all great but
I mean funny the discussion tends to
like
focus on like how do we not accidentally
make like a hell-like
we're pretty happy with not making a
hell-like that's like a good first
standard but there's a whole separate
discussion of like okay well how do you
go from earth to heaven right forget
about avoiding hell let's go from earth
Devon and there's a whole discussion
about that like what does heaven
actually mean people are very there's a
there's a big lack of creativity when
people think about heaven
it's it's not that interesting and
there's there's a number of reasons for
that for example if you look at the
dials that we have in our brain the
dials for pain versus pleasure for
example like sexual pleasure like sexual
pleasure you can turn that dial up
reasonably high but the torture pain oh
my god it's it's kind of like you can go
up to like floor five a pleasure but the
basement has like a thought there's like
a thousand basement levels it's like it
goes from like negative a thousand to
five right that's that's like the
elevator of pain and pleasure and the
reason is just because pain has so many
useful functions you know evolutionarily
right it just tells you like no don't do
this like avoid this this is horrible
like this will disable you Rekha's pain
is like hey you can't you're gonna
completely destroy your chance of
survival
where's pleasure is like yeah great
you're doing well you know I think it's
like keep doing that there's there's a
rather I guess to be more precise
there's there's more ways to instantly
have game over than to guarantee success
like if I have sex that's really really
good but it's for my genes but it's not
as good as the badness for my genes of
getting my wiener cut off mm-hm
so you're never gonna have sex that
feels as good as getting your wiener cut
off feels bad mmm and there's thousands
of examples of yeah exactly there's more
ways to screw yourself over and there's
no ways there's no evolutionary way to
help yourself more than you can hurt
yourself okay so the conversations are
both around the the initial programming
ethic and philosophy and morality
and then where that's going to develop
out to which seems to be the one of the
most important points because that then
both talks about the prosperity function
as well as avoidance of malevolence and
other sure yeah so you talk about the
prosperity function to building
they I so like I said a lot of the focus
is just like man how do you just how do
you even make the prosperity function
that's anywhere near what humans care
about right because the moment that you
flick on like a randomly chosen AI it's
like oh hi I'm a randomly chosen AI let
me just you know get myself let me just
recharge my battery okay in order to
recharge my battery I'm just gonna use
all the atoms in there as energy like
oops and I know that sounds crazy but
like it turns out to like be like a
really easy mistake to make once you
once you like dive into it like maybe
something like the agents function is
about maximizing happiness and so then
there's some sort of oh well I learned
that to be to help people become happy
they need access to fresh foods and so
then there's a lot of food that's being
made and so be like how do you optimize
it so that it knows that well we eat
about three times a day we don't want to
turn all of the San Mateo at Crystal
Springs reservoir area into a strawberry
field we want to keep it I mean even the
stuff you're describing though is still
stuff like you know it's not that bad
text like you're talking about like oh
it's not doing optimal zoning but it's
like it's if it's doing zoning at all as
a bug destroying the world that's pretty
good yeah I we we we need to be in that
Lin that that latter Park of of just
making it so that this whole like
destroying the world thing is like just
so out of the question yes and I haven't
really made a stronger argument like I
keep referring to the idea that like you
flick it on and it accidentally destroys
the world and I I don't have off without
my head like the strongest argument why
that's true but it there are a lot of
convincing arguments so one thing is
just like if you try to write down a
very precise wish for the most basic
thing you want like if my house is on
fire and my grandma's in there I want to
rescue my grandma from the burning
building and you program that into an AI
and you have to be a lot more precise
than you think because there could be
three other people in the building maybe
it could rescue all four at the same
time instead of just one right and you
also don't know like maybe it actually
maybe I like in order to rescue her it
does something where it like causes a
lot of other damage like I don't know
maybe it like poisons are in the process
of saving her from the building and she
dies like a little later but even that
like I said I don't know like the
strongest example off about my head but
it's like or maybe it's so really the
computer systems need to have perception
of space-time causality they need to be
powerful dynamically adjusting agents
kind of like we are in a sense but well
it's rational and what's interesting is
even if you assume that they're very
dynamic and they really they really get
it they really know how to get their way
in the world what's actually hard is
making them understand the weird
combination of stuff that humans
consider like a normal good world it's
actually very complicated to express
what we think is a normal the world so
for example the the robot or the AI
might think like oh well you know humans
like to have enough food to eat so let
me make sure they have enough food date
but the problem is it's like where's the
limit of exactly how much food so it's
just like again do you just turn every
atom into food for humans because like a
way they also needed like you know pause
so the perception system itself would
need to be aware of the eight billion
humans off and they're eating where all
the food is there's lots of variables to
to put into the calculations yeah so a
lot of a lot of what we take for granted
is that we don't have like that much
power you know what I'm saying so if I
try my hardest to feed myself that's
okay I'm not gonna destroy the world
because I just inherently don't have
that much power over the world but if
you tell a computer to do it by
assumption it's so smart that it sees
paths like every you know the whole
world is like it's Plato said like once
he gets smart enough that's basically
what you see you know from the
perspective of other animals humans are
like you know other animals they think
they have their own niches you don't
have your own niches okay if humans are
here like we can basically treat any
part of the world as our play-doh
doesn't to a pretty high degree you know
what I'm saying like you think you're
safe in Antarctica no we can go there
too you know what I'm saying like even
though you wouldn't think a human could
go there so similarly and by the way
when we were like Apes
you know people a lot of animals
probably thought they were pretty safe
you know like apes are not as strong as
like you know a buffalo right but now in
reality if we want to gun down every
Buffalo in the world we can write like
it's not a big deal for us and so
similarly like AI it's just gonna be so
powerful it's gonna be again it's not
just tell me what you want to see in the
world and I'll make it happen and so
that level of power that gives you an
intuition for why it's like we really
have to be clear about what not to
destroy yeah yeah okay let's rock um
some of the other questions on the way
out what do you think is the overall
meaning of this human experience overall
mean yeah I mean so you know the
question is obviously not super well
specified in the sense that like it's
hard to even know what an answer looks
like you know and I'm things like what
is an example of an answer that's even
about it - a question like that right
there are some that we've had that are
pretty solid okay what's one maximizing
consciousness creativity meaning
flourishing yeah okay sure so I mean the
thing about the meaning question right
is like that you have to put in the
context of the fact that we evolved you
know in a universe so like the universe
started with no consciousness and then
we like we're kind of like accidentally
here you know what I'm saying like it's
it's kind of like if you I could start a
universe from scratch right now like I
could you know have you ever heard of
Conway's Game of Life it's like it's a
two dimensional grid of black and white
cells and you can make some of them
black and some of them white and it's
like an infinite grid so it's an infant
grid all the cells start wait you can
make some of them black and then you
turn on the simulation and it just
evolves by itself where every cell has a
rule of whether it turns black or white
based on what's going on around it so
it's a completely passive simulation and
if you look at if you understand
Conway's Game of Life that is like a
model of a universe like our universe
could at the lowest level literally be
Conway's Game of Life like once they
unpack the atoms unpack the quarks
unpack quantum theory it literally could
be running on a Conway's Game of Life
and it's a useful thing to think about
because it's it shows it shows you what
it's like to create a universe like
everybody gives God so much credit like
oh my god God created the universe
that's amazing it's not that hard to
create a universe okay I can show you
how to do it on my computer and so once
you know what a universe looks like it
and
you know you know how like you know what
happens after that where if you have you
know a natural selection dynamic right
if you have molecules that are capable
of getting into a cycle or they mutate
and evolve into like cellular organisms
and you get a process of evolution going
eventually if you run it long enough you
will get a species that gets intelligent
that then starts asking the question why
right like my baby Ezra I was looking at
him like he doesn't really have
consciousness yet right he's still just
he's four months old so it's kind of
funny because I'm looking at him he has
he doesn't have any sense of what's the
meaning of life but I know that one day
he's gonna have a module inside of him
that's gonna start asking what's the
meaning of life right unless I he
suffers a you know brain damage and
never develops that module so this is
just how universes play out that people
start asking what the meaning is well
the meaning is that we're you know we're
running in this evolving universe or
evolving simulation it's possible that
we have simulation gods who created the
universe a certain way but then you can
just ask okay well the simulation gods
right the alien teenagers who started us
off in the simulated universe what was
their goal right and maybe they had some
goal okay but who created the alien
teenagers so it's hard to really answer
the meaning question I feel like it's
more of like a perspective question like
putting myself in perspective the way I
just did like I'm like a character in
one of these universes and then you can
ask the question like okay well why is
there something instead of nothing like
why why doesn't every possible universe
exist and then the answer is well maybe
it does maybe every possible universe
does exist and that's called a tegmark
level for the tegmark level you for
universe where he thinks that every
logically possible universe does exist
in some sense even though it feels like
we're only in one of them so that's kind
of as far as I've gotten to the question
of like why is there meaning and it's it
might not be a complete answer but it
certainly eliminates some of the crap
other people are saying mm-hmm
you know we can tell that you've jumped
around between a lot of the different
schools of thought around the subject
which is always really good to to here
it is in the sense this most first
principal question why are we here what
is the nature of this reality it's a
very important philosophical question
they can give people a good amount of of
diving into some of the most important
churches and philosophies and sciences
and and maybe even help guide them
towards some sort of actualization in
the world that they may have been on a
wrong path prior to asking themselves
these questions so these questions can
sometimes elicit people to go on more
more aligned paths with their ultimate
purpose and destiny how about how about
what are your thoughts about the
relationship between free will and
determinism sure yeah so my opinion is a
kind of the standard one for the Center
for pi directionality I think maybe not
official but probably most of the people
share it which is like so I think the
universe is deterministic so I do think
that it just follows rules predictable
rules which is nice as opposed to just
having a huge component of fundamental
randomness and and for the for the
physically knowledgeable audience I
guess I believe in the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
which doesn't have any randomness
built-in so there's no collapse or
anything so it's just a clockwork
universe so that's how I think the
universe works but then the question is
well what's going on with freewill it's
not that hard like imagine watching
somebody else like doing their thing
like watching another human or watching
a smart computer play chess imagine
watching something do their thing from
your perspective you don't know what
they're gonna do right they seem like
they're they're driven by desires and
they have strategies but you it's hard
to predict exactly what they're gonna do
right I don't know what the the
chess-playing computer is gonna do next
if it's trying to kick my ass at chess
if you look at your own brain sometimes
you don't know exactly what your own
brain is gonna do right and then
eventually you end up doing something
and sometimes you you even know why you
did it because you know you did it at
the end of a process so for example like
let's say that I'm just trying to get to
a place rather I'm just trying to drive
to my hotel room from the airport okay
so if I look at the next intersection I
can't tell you if I'm gonna turn left or
right but I can tell you what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna check Google Maps right and
then I'm gonna look at whatever it says
and then I'm gonna do what it does I
check Google Maps and says turn left and
then I turn left okay so I didn't know
what I was gonna do
but I just you know there was a process
like at the end of the day I ran the
process and then I did it and that's the
free will is what you feel like when you
don't yet know what you're gonna do or
you don't yet know when somebody else is
going to do but you play out a process
and then that determines what you're
gonna do how do you feel about our
disconnection from nature and how that
has led to so many of the issues we have
in our civilization yeah our
disconnection from nature um
well in a sense we are in a sense we
aren't so like you know the the drive to
build up stuff is very human right I
mean the whole the reason why our bodies
are the way we are is because we we
actually evolve together with some of
our primitive technology right so the
reason we're like weak compared to Apes
you know like a chimpanzee baby can
completely kick the ass of like a UFC
fighter you know I'm sad not a baby but
like a child so humans are like very
weak and the reason is just because
we're able to you know use our brains to
get around and the reason our brains are
so big relative to our bodies is because
we we had cooked food so it's okay like
we don't we don't have to we're able to
support this really hungry brain because
we just cook our food and the fire does
a lot of the work of the digestion so
we're getting this calorie rich food so
it's already kind of natural for us to
be like coddled just to some degree now
the amount that we're call of today is
insane right like even the fact that we
have like running water and like quality
toilets like that's already like amazing
right we're living in Star Wars
basically so I don't think it's that bad
I think it's mostly just good and
awesome I think that most people's lives
can be described as being a pain in the
ass like most people's lives have been a
pain in the ass and today they're much
more interesting much less of a pain in
the ass I think it's great there's some
downsides right like the fact that you
know we're losing we just we don't
really know first of all we don't know
how bad it could be right I think a lot
of the people who are whining they just
don't realize that they're whining about
the difference between being on level 9
and being on level 10 right when when
most of humanity is just on level 1
right and then I just need a sense of
perspective I like just chill out
because we're in it we're all in a good
place
yeah and if they have to go live with
nature for
week I think they'd get that yeah mm-hmm
yeah yes very true that basic needs like
we mentioned the beginning of increased
around the world simultaneously are our
disconnection from nature the air that
we pollute that we also breathe the
deforestation that we do that we also
again as part of our air cycle sure but
deforestation is only the main reason
deforestation there's so much more right
the pollution of the oceans and the
relationship that that has to the water
cycle it's just inevitable that if we
continue having ignorant with the
interconnectedness of everything on the
planet we're just gonna have more and
more issues arise we're moving into
metropolis is at unprecedented rates
where we are disconnected from the
cosmos we're disconnected from the farms
we're disconnected from more and more
the things although we have the toilets
and we have the electricity and we have
the gadgets so we have to really be
aware that yes you are right there are
these toilets lights gadgets
simultaneously the disconnection that
you have from never going to a farm
we're never seeing the billions of stars
that these are very serious things that
when you throw something away that you
don't know that it goes to the landfill
we realize the interconnectedness of
everything and then that augments our
perspective to become better stewards of
the planet as we do this evolution at
the same time so I feel like you're you
have a mental picture where you're kind
of want to you want to get back into
harmony right with nature how do you
feel about that that but is that is that
kind of is that accurate
is that like a good summary of what
you're saying let's get back into
harmony with nature
well simultaneously building the future
okay so my point is harmony is provably
not a thing in nature like everybody
thinks nature is all about harmony okay
imagine your tree imagine your god
you're trying to design a universe with
harmony in it
okay the last thing you do is you take
two organisms and they go hardcore
having the opposite desires clashing
with each other and that's what you see
all over the natural world right so you
see the Fox who wants nothing more than
to catch the rabbit right and the rabbit
who wants nothing more than to like
escape or like poison the Fox you know
saying they're completely at
cross-purposes and you see that all over
the place like if you follow this
channel nature is scary right I said the
other day I just saw like a bird come
over and see a mouse on a cliff and the
bird just like keeps nudging the mouse
just nudges them off the cliff and then
the mouse Falls and dies and then their
bird eats it that kind of stuff is going
on all over the place in nature okay so
us being dicks to the Buffalo that's the
accurate course of nature there's no
effing harmony some organisms put the
other organisms in their teeth and chew
like it's a fricking bar fight out there
in nature and so the planet really is
our bi TCH like it really is we're just
trying to optimize how the planet
supports us like I don't give a damn how
how polluted it is if it doesn't cause
us humans a problem so many of the the
ancient wisdoms that have been around
very very long tens of thousands of
years much longer than our little
25-year chunks of life a lot of them
talk about the harmony including
actually what you just described which
are some of those instances of in nature
at the same time for every one of those
instances that you listed there's all of
these other examples of nature being
extremely gorgeously interconnected and
intertwined in ways that again that if
we vibe with at a deeper level and just
really embody and understand that we
ourselves can follow similar principles
to maximize flourishing so keeping a
mentality of like I don't care how
polluted is as long as it doesn't affect
me or the civilization right is at the
same time can be phrased in a way that
is let's have energy unlimited
energy for anyone at the push of a
button that is created by the most
optimal nuclear fusion that has again
just zero emissions into the planet
period and so it's just you know there's
always different ways to frame these
statements like if a child hears that I
don't care how polluted it is long as it
doesn't affect human civilization I
think that's a frame that the child can
think well then let's like increase the
pollution to a certain level as long as
it you know versus the well let's
actually not do that process that's fine
but it's it's a really deep point that
nature is not in harmony like that is a
fundamental fact about nature if you
look at nature it's because I could
design you a universe where nature isn't
harmony it's not that hard you just give
everybody goals that are pulling in the
same direction and then you can have the
water cycle is that not harmony I mean
it's an equilibrium but it's I mean
harmony like sure I'm look you can find
some harmonies I can swing a pendulum
and that's like kind of a nice harmony
but if you look at nature if you look at
animals it's I mean the whole idea of
evolution by natural selection is is
selection pressure is competition got to
the death the Earth orbiting the star
and the seasons happening on the planet
sharing the water cycle and even like
you described this idea of of biological
hierarchies and natural selection that
all these things can be viewed as
harmony although well you are aiming to
phrase it in a way that is not hard look
the water say I can show you a lot of
things that are nice harmonies but if
you go and look at the fundamental
dynamic of evolution it is fundamentally
an anti harmony it's like the farthest
possible thing from harmony is evolution
if you had harmony you'd never have
evolution you'd never have selection
pressure because the first organism to
ever reproduce itself you just get a lot
of that that's it you just stay that
would stay with that because there'd be
no evolution this conversation is coming
to this point of which selection
pressure and natural selection is
actually and viewed in your perspective
as a non harmonious and it is
fundamentally not harmonious and in
other people's perspectives is actually
viewed as part of the harmonies I mean
they're just not thinking clearly about
what's actually going on like they don't
realize what it actually is it
nice thought to say that it's an Armony
but if you look at it because again
imagine your god from scratch you're
making a universe from scratch show me
what a universe looks like when it's in
harmony show me show me what life in
harmony looks like show me what life not
in harmony looks like now look at our
universe that's life not in harmony
that's really what it is life in harmony
looks like all the all the animals have
the same goals
all the animals agree that everybody
should have their own territory and
respect each other's rights right like
what we have today in the United States
right as with a functioning government
the government keeps us in harmony
that's the job and it doesn't reasonably
well but what you have in the animal
kingdom or the whole kingdom of life is
really not harmony because you can
contrast it with what harmony actually
is this is this is fair one of the ways
to potentially also look at it would be
maybe there's a way to design as we
continue to design universes maybe there
are ways to design a universe where all
of the all of what is in functioning is
in a deeper level of harmony than even
what we have here in our universe so
sure sure
and then how about what do you think is
the most beautiful thing in the world I
mean I don't have like such a
well-developed and sense and focus on
beauty that I that I can really tell you
what's the most beautiful thing in the
world I think my sense of beauty is like
the average pedestrian sense of beauty
right so certainly you know beautiful
women beautiful men I guess you know
just beautiful paintings I just I don't
have any any particular insight on
what's beautiful because I think
ultimately the you know the the
computation of beauty happens in
everybody's brain I guess it's kind of
like asking asking me like what's like
the best golf swing and like I don't
know you know you just I can tell you
that throwing the golf club is a bad
swing it can't tell you what's a great
golf swing I guess I have some
appreciation for certain beauty of like
in my field of software engineering
right I can tell you what's like a
beautiful piece of code a little bit
better than average but at the end of
the day I think beauty is just one of
our many things that we like right like
beauty you like good taste right we like
life and baby
and knowledge right so this is just all
good stuff that we like ingredients one
of the things do you think this is
simulation I think it more likely than
not as a simulation it's hard for me to
give you an exact probability but like
gun to my head if I have to guess
whether we're in a simulation or not I'm
gonna guess yes because you know I'm not
the the first person to figure it out
it's you know Nick Bostrom's simulation
argument are you familiar yeah okay so
maybe just to recap it really quick it's
just it's the idea of like look do you
think that intelligent civilizations
such as our own eventually create
computer simulations of other
intelligent species seems like probably
yes but that's that's one question
that's part of the argument and then
another question is like okay so are we
a simulation and you know and and how
likely are they to create a simulation
so I may be leaving out a part of the
argument but the basic idea is like
don't you think you and I are eventually
going to create simulations if we can if
we have the computing power to it's like
can we do we want to will we okay so if
that's all true
then don't you think that we're not the
first intelligences don't you think
we're just in somebody else's simulation
like why should we think that we're the
first because it was probably a big
chain of people simulating each other
and like Humanity in the year 2100 is
probably gonna be running a simulation
which is itself running a simulation
right so why do we think we're level one
like what why don't we think we're just
an experiment about an alien teenager
playing The Sims and we're the Sims like
why shouldn't we think that earlier on
this has been such a fun conversation I
really appreciate you coming onto our
show thank you no problem thank you so
much for comin Graham yeah thank you
thank you incredible work that you've
been doing throughout your life it's
incredible worldview you've been
building out as well thereon yeah it's
been fun going back and forth with you
on all these subjects thanks on yeah I
appreciate that you know deep and
untraditional questions yeah yeah God we
got a press into those deep and on
traditional ones with as many of the
different leaders in the fields as
possible thanks everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on that episode let us know what you
think and have more conversation with
your friends families co-workers people
online about the topics that we talked
about today about things like
relationship here
go and give that a go in relationship
eurocom give that a go let us know your
thoughts about how your experience is
going with that and about the the nuance
that we talked about regarding that
subject and its depth and also all these
other philosophical questions we talked
about let us know what you're thinking
in the comments below again relationship
eurocom also Leon's LinkedIn profiles
Twitter profile go and give him a follow
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the leaders around the world that you
believe in support them and help them
grow you can find simulation in all of
our links below
that's a patreon paypal cryptocurrencies
design cold merchants get paid all those
links are below and shout out to our
co-producer or shapiro we love you very
much thank you and that is all folks
thanks for tuning in and much love we
will see you soon
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]